and now  ladies and Gentlemen please welcome  Whitney Houston  [Applause]  a common criticism of you your music  isn't black enough who said that that's  just Bull and it makes me angry actually  it's hateful and uninformed our whole  life she ain't black no she ain't white  enough well how about she's not obedient  enough  how about she ain't fearful enough  music is not a color to me it has no  boundaries I've seen what I want to sing  be how I want to be and reach as big an  audience as I can  [Music]  [ __ ] you  me your daddy's princess  we're building something here see you  just keep singing Daddy  my money  I trusted you do you want me to look out  for me  [Music]  YouTube has spent a lot of time together  it's damaging the brand since winter  little girl become the brand I miss that  don't even worry about it you're Whitney  Houston  [Music]  [Applause]  love  love millions of people  [Applause]  than I ever know  [Applause]